comme chaque semaine
on commence par les petites sottise les
petites galéjade des chroniqueurs et de
cyril bien sûr c'est une séquence à
picorer comme ma saucisse cocktail c'est
sa conjointe une scène on le fait mal au
genou et de sa carte green side de pépé
et on commence tout de suite non pas
avec bnp mais avec la foire du trône
plus aisés barre du haut niveau en vue
autour de lui retirer cette phrase
porcelaine ça risque de casser
rechange et invasive et scoop c'est
finalement guillaume genton qui a plaqué
delphine wespiser le bond de ce look you
on va voir si ça va être mieux qu'avec
moi parce qu'avec moi c'était vraiment
c'est pitoyable c'était très bon
donc c'est très bien donc c'est très
fine hyper mieux définis tu passe à
autre chose
[Rires]
c'est une écossais sur l'udc
regardez-moi cyril comment ils adorent
ces petits moments ou coquines ou minou
[Applaudissements]
chez les rouges matthieu delormeau veut
goûter aux poteaux de série
[Applaudissements]
ok
et regardez moi comment ils sont tous
jaloux de roger bontems brasse-camarade
ce que c'est un ex danseur strip teaser
très connu en alsace c'est vrai
arrivé à roger l'april un camion
était à 30 ans et maintenant visiblement
jean lassalle s'y connaît un peu mieux
en politique qu'en motogp fabre est
devenu champion du monde en motogp et
fort et comment il fait comment tu fais
un cas pareil tu as peur un peu ou pas
non c'est monsieur toi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et on finit avec loto de la citation des
semaines cinéma bien sûr et à l'envers
parce que vous regardez le téléphone
jamais d'avis jamais de la vie chacun
sont le téléphone c'est comme un slip
arriver si on regarde dedans on est
toujours déçu
c'est vrai
le sens des métaphores oui bah oui bah
oui bah oui oui je lis beaucoup et hyper
oui je dis bon giral il le sait lire
s'est refusé de mourir je savais que
quand j'ai sorti cette phrase je croyais
que c'était d'oman et en fait c'est guy
deveault pas son nom est persuadé que
c'était dommage mais je vous jure c'est
sorti comme ça moi ça s'appelle une
figure en
bas mais brillants cerveaux comment
savoir lequel des deux a sorti le
premier abbas et
j'ai appelé kido
qui dit
série les téléspectateurs ont raté
pendant la pub votre pâte dans ce
magnifique incroyable campbell a pendant
la pub ah oui il arrive qu'il ya
quelques minutes eh bien vous avez
toujours dit que tu es pmp c'était une
émission média et dance wii donc on va
pas se mentir il n'y a pas que des
experts médias autour de sa table oui
c'est vrai mais je vous rassure ya pas d
experts en danse aussi regardez bien ces
danses avec l'armée
sur une danse désarticulé du mec un
malade en lui ont fait il faut le faire
ni corps
[Applaudissements]
sur une danse de fraudeurs de la ligne
13 bernard montiel
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sur une danse de labrador alpin
guillaume genton
[Applaudissements]
sur une dans ce cadre un gars on a
vraiment envie de le pet à benjamin
castaldi
[Musique]
dès lors d'autres le blizzard
sur une danse de la retrouve dans le
genou il s'appelle m libre
[Applaudissements]
sur une danse du mec en boîte qu'ils
aient envie de kehl à 5 heures du matin
souli la nina
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la série est de 12 ans mais plus battu
magazine et cherche à vos joueurs
[Rires]
étaient paraît n'avoir commis deux
grosses heures
impressionnant c'est le latin en vous
qui
est unisexe
[Rires]
merci merci madame prochain on ne sait
pas qui nous sommes
et
ça
ne faisait pas attention on a vu mais
vous êtes aussi un très grand
interviewer on sent que l'élection
présidentielle a réuni pour garder bien
la tête des invités quand vous leur
posez les questions les plus sérieuses
je coupe à la promo ici c'est la
meilleure de la salle à partir de là
[Musique]
vous adorez j'ai envie de l'année manger
chez ma mère thomas
s'abattent sur ma vie et je veux des
boulets que des poulets
des balades jeux des boulots
[Musique]
je n'aurais bien embrouillée le tunisien
mais il va me défoncer alors merci
benjamin d'argent rédacteur en chef de
closer d'être avec nous vous avez une
sacrée paire de couilles
fabrice di vizio et non tout
est bas divisio et 2 to
[Musique]
tous
fabrice kamion pensez bien
menace émise en costaud par une hôtesse
du parc des princes pour déjà ne
l'aurais pas fait si on permettait cette
viande en deux secondes wemmel voreppe
en tout cas moi mais je préfère dans
deux secondes parce que j'ai ma mère se
cache et son brio au piano jaune
non mais c'est vrai que les clubs
échangistes à l'arrêt dont mes clubs
échangistes est vrai pourquoi ils
restent ouverts alors si je peux les
années visite et
[Rires]
je rigole mais là je sois tu as l'air
touche à fond en l'annonçant c'est pas
parce qu'ils ont mangé un caprice des
dieux tu vas nous faire ch
est parfait en mission humanitaire au
bangladesh bravo mon chéri bo bobo qui
fait un travail fort bien le même sens
je ne pouvais pas vous en partir sans
vous remettre du on l'a vu à l'appel le
principe pour les téléspectateurs qui ne
connaîtraient pas cette séquence je vais
fouiller un peu dans les archives du
cinoche de la téloche pour retrouver les
chroniqueurs qui essayent d'arrondir
leurs fins de mois ça s'appelle le on
l'a vu regardez
[Musique]
et si vous demandiez où est passé
nicolas pernikoff eh bien on l'a vu au
camping des flots bleus regard des
bleus
alors là tu ne t'attends pas patrick
mais on a vu bardy le mook se met au rap
et ça y est ou plutôt
[Musique]
on continue avec gilles verdez toujours
aussi vénère quand on essaye de peixoto
manquait
pas content j'ai lu on a vu aussi
isabelle morini bosc et ça y est elle a
enfin dû son pantalon temporaire
[Rires]
fabrice di vizio en train de boucler ses
cadeaux de noël ça y est il est prête
pour rébellion
[Musique]
et cyril on sait pourquoi vous n'étiez
pas là la semaine dernière on vous a vu
en thaïlande plus précisément pattaya
avec de gros problèmes de transit envie
de plus en pus cela il va quand même
temps toujours
[Applaudissements]
c